امام تضخما فاق الثلاثين في المئه للسنه
الثالثه على التوالي وطبقه متوسطه باتت من
الماضي نظام طهران مصرا على حل واحد وهي
معالجه الاعراض للاسباب
بالرفع من ميزانيه الدعايه والمؤسسات
الامنيه الميزانيه الجديده رفعت من
ميزانيه الحرس الثوري بقيمه 28% لتبلغ نحو
58 مليار دولار 30 مليار دولار منها مخصصه
لدعم اذرع ايران في الخارج من رواتب
وتسليح ودعايه البدايه من الرواتب يتقاضى
كل عنصر من ميليشيات ايران في سوريا مثلا
250 دولارا شهريا عناصر ميليشيا الحوثي
نحو 200 دولار اما متوسط رواتب عناصر
ميليشيا حزب الله اللبنانيه فيصل الى
2300 دولار شهريا الا انها بدورها تخلو من
العداله جمال الدين ابرو مساعد الرئيس
البرلمان الايراني استولى على جزء من
مرتبات ميليشيا ايران في اليمن والعراق
وسوريا وهو يحصل تحصل على ميزانيه احتسبت
فيها رواتب تتراوح بين 500 والف دولار
بينما لم تتجاوز الرواتب في الواقع 200
دولار اذا ما استثنينا طبعا عناصر حزب
الله فابروند اختلس نصف رواتب 200 الف
مقاتل تابع لميليشيا ايران في الشرق
الاوسط صفقه الكل صفقه الكل فيها مستفيد
فهو وعبر منصبه بالبرلمان لا يتدخل في
ميزانيه فيلق القدس بل يساهم في اطفاء
السريه عليها بينما يسمح له بالتصرف يسمح
له بالتصرف بحريه في رواتب الميليشيات في
الخارج هذه المعادله جاءت كنتيجه لمقتل
قاسم سليماني خليفته باتا غير قادر على
ضبط هذه المهام والنتيجه توزيع المهام على
شخصيات كثيره تت نافس على السلطه وتتفق في
سعيها نحو الثراء